all right so this is where normally I'd
put up the dozens of emails that I get
saying things like David I can tell that
you are a shill for Elizabeth Warren
because when her polling goes up you
talk about it but when her polling goes
down you don't talk about it or David I
can tell you hate Bernie because when
Bernie's polling goes up you don't talk
about it and when Bernie's polling goes
down you gleefully talk about it and of
course none of that's true but when you
look at the facts the truth is we've had
essentially six straight months of
Bernie's polling going more or less know
where he was at 14 in late April and he
was at 14 three weeks ago well we've had
six straight months of Elizabeth
Warren's polling climbing from 8 in
April to as high as 27 a couple of weeks
ago I just tell you what is happening
and for the first time in many months
Bernie's polling is showing signs of
life so is Pete Budaj edges but we'll
get to that shortly and it's happening
at the expense of Joe Biden and
Elizabeth Warren let's look at the
numbers for which I am of course merely
a humble messenger not the pollster as
you can see at the top of the graph
declines for Joe Biden and Elizabeth
Warren Joe Biden down about two and a
half points in the last three weeks
Elizabeth Warren also losing some
momentum down about five points in the
last three weeks who is gaining in the
last three weeks well it's Bernie and
also Pete Budaj as you see Bernie the
blue line popping up from about 14 to
now more than 17 a three-point gain for
Bernie you also see the purple line on
the graph this is Pete Budaj edge mayor
Pete from South Bend Indiana climbing
from just about four points a couple of
weeks ago now polling about seven
percent this is the highest Pete Budaj
Edge has pulled since early May
otherwise things are basically unchanged
Kamala Harris continuing a more or less
slow decline since early July
everything else really not not much else
going on with her
Andrew yang still has his two-and-a-half
average Tulsi Gabbard has her one point
three average Beto still has around two
and klobuchar around two so what do we
make of all this well bernie is still in
it that's what we make of it Bernie's
doing what he has to do if he wants a
shot at this thing gaining back some of
the support that he lost all the way
back in April when Joe Biden entered
this race if you were supporting Bernie
you should be pleased he did what he had
to do in the last three weeks which is
he picked up three points in three weeks
now with the debate number five coming
up he has to keep it going and it's
particularly important because we have
this fifth debate coming up on November
20th it is an opportunity conceivably
hypothetically for someone to make a big
showing and make a gain in the polls but
as I said when I appeared on PBS a
couple of weeks ago the further into the
primary we get the less that there is to
gain from having a good debate showing
because the candidates positions are
known the candidates personalities are
known the candidates presences presences
that's a difficult word to say their
presences on the stage are known because
they've been around for longer and we've
been watching a whole bunch of debate so
far so the further we get into this
thing the debates actually represent a
potential liability the debates
represent an opportunity to do something
wrong and to lose support in the polls
the downside of the debates becomes
bigger as we get further into it
particularly because there is less time
to make up for missteps while the
possibility of some big gain due to the
debates diminishes so that's just a
reality that's not about Bernie
specifically now for debate number five
we have nine people already qualified we
have Beto Tulsi and Julian Castro
pending some of the requirements so we
could conceivably end up with twelve
people on the debate stage again which
I guess it diminishes the speaking time
for each person which in a sense reduces
the possibility that they make some
major gaffe or faux pas and put their
foot in their mouth
but once again we are not going to get
deep discussion about any issue quite
frankly from a debate that has 12 people
up on the stage the qualification period
for debate 5 which is on November 20th
ends on November 13th a week before so
they basically have two weeks left to
either be in or out
Beto Tulsi and who Leon Castro
so we will see ultimately who makes that
stage Bernie Sanders people who are
following Bernie supporting Bernie
should be pleased a point a week I mean
listen Elizabeth Warren got to her peak
of 27 point whatever it was gaining
about a point and a half to two points a
month so a point a week is a lot we
haven't had polls for about five days
and I'm guessing by tomorrow we'll have
some new ones and we will see how Bernie
is doing their duet cappucci paid-for de
Grazia Mila one of our sponsors making
the David Pakman show possible is Babel
the language learning app and you'll get
25% off a subscription to Babel when you
click the link under this video
Babel was founded in 2007 and now has
over a million paying subscribers
worldwide as one of the world's leading
language learning apps their learning
method has been examined numerous times
in scientific studies including one at
Yale in 2019 which found that 100
percent of participants who used Babel
were able to improve their oral
proficiency with a new language within
just three months research found that
users learning Spanish on Babel only
needed to use the app for an average of
15 hours over a two-month period to
cover the requirements for one college
semester of Spanish I recently went to
Italy and used Babel to brush up on my
Italian for a few weeks leading up to
the trip and I was actually surprised at
how much I was able to absorb in such a
short amount of time
after practicing Italian on the babble
app I was able to hold some
conversations with locals in Italy I
could understand a lot more of the
Italian that I was hearing and the
progress I made was extremely inspiring
in keeping me going and continuing to
use the app to get even better I'm also
about to use the app to start learning
German which I'm looking forward to I
really would recommend Babel to anyone
who watches our show and you can save
25% on a subscription to Babel when you
click the link right underneath this
video